salut aujourd'hui vous avez vu c'est une
caméra différentes et c'est qu'une prise
de vue un petit peu différente j'ai eu
un nokia 8 et le nokia n8 la
particularité de pouvoir filmer en avant
le devant et l'arrière de l'écran voilà
cyber dont le fameux fait beaucoup rire
et je me suis dit qu'il y avait quand
même des vidéos génial à faire avec ça
je vous en reparlerai à la fin sur les
idées que je vais vous allez me dire ce
que vous en pensez ou pas en tout cas
pour aujourd'hui et comme vous l'avez
sûrement vu dans le titre j'ai dû mettre
ça dans le titre c'est vraiment le bon
matos pour apprendre quelque chose que
vous m'aviez souvent demandé l'année
dernière et un petit peu cette année de
comment on fait pour mélanger les cartes
à l'américaine à chaque fois que j'ai un
jeu perd je fais ça dans les vidéos
certains et certaines d'entre vous
savent que j'ai fait de la cartomagie
pendant des années donc ok je vous
apprends à faire un mélange américain en
un sens table sans rien alors pour
commencer bien sûr il faut venir d'un
jeu de cartes ça c'est un jeu de 52
cartes c'est à dire c'est un 54 cents et
joker et on va différencier les grandes
tranches ici des petites tranches ici ok
comme cette caméra est situé à l'arrière
du téléphone vous voyez exactement ce
que je vois moi en même temps c'est un
peu osé de cartes toi même tu sais vous
commencez par mettre le majeur et
l'annulaire sur les petites tranches
comme ça l'index vient se recourber
comme ça sur le dos et le pouce mais sur
la petite tranche en pause et donc vous
avez une tenue qui ressemble
grossièrement à ça l'idée je vous
propose de commencer par prix d'entrée
n'est pas ressasser de pouvoir mettre
l'index sur la grande tranche et
l'auriculaire sur l'autre grande tranche
pourquoi je vais vous dire pourquoi pour
pouvoir tenir le jeu comme ceux ci il
doit être tenu fermement vous devez
pouvoir le retourner comme ça à l'envers
sans que toutes les cartes dont on
revient à la position précédente vous
allez place et l'autre main devant dans
le but de réceptionner la moitié du
paquet pour sa l'index va appuyer un
petit peu pour courber les cartes comme
ça ça fait une espèce de pont et le
pouce va effeuiller gentiment les cartes
comme ça lentement alors pour bien
effeuiller il faut pas placer le pousse
à la perpendiculaire de la petite
tranche supérieure au contraire si vous
l'emmenez presque parallèle ça va vous
permettre de laisser tomber les cartes
tranquillement donc en appuyant sur
l'index et en laissant le pouce comme ça
lâche et des cartes aux fermetures comme
dans tous les domaines fait les choses
étape par étape et entraînez-vous à
chaque étape avant de passer à la
suivante vous allez donc essayé à peu
près la moitié du paquet qui va tomber
dans la main gauche
la main droite va relever comme ça ce
demi paquet pour le placer dans la même
position en symétrie parfaite les cartes
elles se font face en dessous chaque
petite tranche vous avez le majeur et
l'annulaire ans au dessus de chaque
petite frange vous avez le pouce et vous
avez les index comme ça qu'ils peuvent
appuyer dans le dos des cartes
je pense que jusqu'ici tout va bien je
pense aussi que je suis
près de la caméra mais comme j'ai pas
les bras assez long en fait pour pour le
faire sinon remarquer ce que j'ai fait
sous les petites tranches
il ya vraiment une phalange complète qui
dépasse qui déborde alors c'est vraiment
important que ça déborde parce qu'à un
moment donné va falloir replié un petit
peu comme ça sous les paquets pour les
tenir et c'est d'ailleurs notre
prochaine étape maintenant vous allez
force et l'annulaire et le majeur pour
écraser pour retenir un petit peu comme
cela vous fait bien voir les positions
comme ça vous pourrez remettre la vidéo
si vous avez besoin les index vont
appuyer un peu pour courber l'ensemble
et les pousses vont essayer l'écart
comme ça cette étape là elle est très
importante à maîtriser avant de passer à
la suite il faut vraiment savoir tenir
ses deux paquets pour pouvoir appuyer
comme ça en les tenant et en effeuillant
sanctionnant donc
retenez bien le pousse pas trop perdre
andy kubert au contraire un peu
parallèle pour effeuiller les cartes le
plus lentement possible
ci après vous savez faire ça vous savez
faire le mélange est américaine donc on
imagine à force d'entêtement vous êtes à
l'aise avec sa baie vous allez faire
exactement la même chose lentement mais
en rapprochant les deux paquets en même
temps sans les rapprocher ça donne ça et
en les rapprochant en même temps ça
donne ça vous voyez que les cartes ont
commencé à fabriquer un petit peu gels
enfoncé encore un peu plus là vous avez
quasiment fini vous voyez bien que mes
indexons toujours sur le dos et que les
annuaires et les majeures retiennent le
reste contre la paume de la main il vous
reste plus qu'à appuyer sur le dessus là
où il ya la jonction et de tout cours b
en bas en retenant toujours avec avec
les annulaire et les majeures pour faire
littéralement un pont un humain versées
mais vraiment là les pussy fort sur le
haut parce que sinon tout ce bar est
partout je peux même lâché mais
annulaire aimé majeurs maintenant parce
que le pont en fête se tient il se
suffit à lui-même
et c'est quand je vais relâcher la
pression du bas c'est à dire d'ici et
d'ici que mes paumes vont se séparer un
peu toujours en tenant avec l'époux sur
le dessus les cartes regarder elle
demande que ça d'ailleurs
elles vont commencer à s'imbriquer pour
se ranger et faire un deck complet je
vous le fais à vitesse normale
on a le jeu ici je fais la séparation
moitié moitié
les mélanges ici comme ça j'ai un brick
un peu je force en faisant mon eu et je
laisse toutes les cartes retombée je
vous conseille donc des effeuillages
lent pareil pour le team usa hésitez pas
à bien forcé quand vous faites le hull
comme ça c'est pas très simple au départ
s'il est bien fait vous pouvez même le
le faire remonter les cartes à l'envers
une fois que la pression allait mise à
des mises voilà et qui en petit bonhomme
je peux vous expliquer rapidement une
coupe ciseaux quand vous avez un jeu
dans les mains et que vous voulez le
couper en général vous prenez comme ça
et puis vous inversez les paquets bon
c'est pas très joli c'est pas très très
fluide la coupe ciseaux elle consiste à
mettre le pouce sur la tranche
inférieure est toujours majeur annulaire
sur la petite tranche supérieure et à se
servir de l'index pour aller choper une
partie du paquet la décoller et
l'emmener sur le côté donc ça fait un
pivot alors qu'en haut on a vraiment
libérés un demi paquet et bien ce demi
paquet vous me mettez dans la fourche
entre le pouce et l'index opposé comme
ça où le récupérer donc ça met le paquet
dans ce qu'on appelle la position de la
donne et vous reposer le jeu de cartes
par au dessus et là vous venez de faire
une coupe très élégante dire que la
coupe celle qu'on fait quand on sait pas
faire cette coupe là c'est juste on
prend un point on fait ça et on égalise
un peu la coupe ciseaux un peu plus
élégante
on prend avec l'index en mai et on peut
même faire un petit mouvement comme
station alors oui j'ai mis en bouteille
dans le champ parce que je trouvais ça
un petit peu moche qu'on voit juste le
sol en tout cas je trouve intéressant ce
double mode sachant qu'en plus la gemmi
en full hd en fait les deux côtés pour
voir déjà ce que ça faisait mais
j'aurais même pu filmer en 4k des deux
côtés en même temps c'est plutôt balèze
un sas à rien les effets spéciaux
auraient par contre ce mode là m'a donné
plusieurs idées des idées de vlog et
surtout qu'on se refasse un petit peu
des vidéos sur le non verbal ensemble
sur la chaîne que je fasse une analyse
de personnes en direct où vous la voyez
d'un côté en temps réel émoi en temps
réel de l'autre qui permettrait vous
aussi de vous entraîner et en tout cas
de me voir parce que si je filme en 4k
forcément on verra mieux alors ma
question elle est là qu'est ce que vous
en force et est ce que ça vous dit dites
moi dans les commentaires dites-moi
également si vous avez d'autres idées
vous savez que je dis vraiment les
commentaires et que je m'en inspire pour
continuer à faire les créations de
vidéos c'est pas genre mais des
commentaires et je m'en fout en fait je
m'en fous pas du tout donc vraiment vous
pouvez discuter et merci également à
nokia qui a bien voulu m'envoyer le
téléphone là qui est le nom qui habitent
tous meilleurs je pense que c'est le
seul téléphone actuellement qui permet
de faire ce genre de vidéos
merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo comme
d'habitude vous pouvez cliquer et vous
abonner n'oubliez pas également que les
places pour l'olympia sont toujours en
vente et que c'est le bon cadeau de noël
idéal vous êtes déjà environ 400 avoir
réservé les liens sont à la description
à très bientôt c'est hier vendredi et
ciao
alors si c'est pas encore fait tu peux
aussi tu abonnés à la chaîne simplement
en cliquant sur le petit rond que tu
vois voilà juste ici c'est ce petit rond
là ça marche depuis la tablette le
téléphone c'est extrêmement pratique il
n'y a plus de raison d'attendre
allez-y abonnez vous c'est cool
[Musique]